il ya comme quelque chose de kafkaïen
dans cette affaire c'est en avril 2019
que julian assange est arrêté par la
police britannique après sept ans de
refuge à l'ambassade équateur à londres
et le 24 février 2020 la justice
anglaise entame la procédure d'examen de
la demande d'extradition américaine
elle statuera sur le bien fondé du
transfert du fondateur de wikileaks aux
états unis où il encourt jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison pour espionnage
le procès dure trois jours à 2 mois que
prévu initialement et d'abord reporté au
18 mai en raison de la pandémie de kovy
de 19 dès le premier jour du procès on
comprend qu'il s'agit d'une affaire
hors-normes tout de suite le choix du
tribunal et du lieu de détention
d'assange interroge le tribunal de
première instance de woolwich
spécialisée dans le jugement des
terroristes les plus dangereux est relié
par un couloir en béton à la prison de
belmarch la plus sécurisée du pays
belmarch est relié au tribunal par un
tunnel c'est une prison de haute
sécurité construite pour le procès de
seize terroristes il n'y a aucune raison
pour que julian s'y trouvent passé 23
heures par jour en cellule est
considérée comme de la torture
mais la juge a dit donné peu de crédit
aux préoccupations exprimées par le
groupe de travail des nations unies sur
les détentions arbitraires
c'est scandaleux selon l'activiste
britannique craig murray ce tribunal
serait la négation pure et simple du
concept de présomption d'innocence le
lieu est glauque
julian assange est traité de facto comme
un terroriste assis à l'arrière du
tribunal derrière une vitre blindée et
tout semble être fait pour restreindre
au maximum l'accès du public au procès
la tribune publique de la salle
d'audience choisi ne contient que 16
sièges bien que la sphère soit d'un
intérêt public incontestable à cette
étape les positions des deux parties
sont claires d'un côté les avocats de
julian assange rappelle le caractère
journalistique des travaux qui valent à
leurs clients d'être emprisonné depuis
plusieurs mois et tentent de démontrer
la nature politique de la demande
américaine de l'autre l'accusation le
camp de washington avance l'argument
selon lequel l'australien aurait dépassé
son rôle de journaliste en publiant des
documents secrets en les réclamants
auprès de sa source il
devient de fait selon eux ni plus ni
moins qu'un espion pour statuer sur la
demande d'extradition la justice
britannique doit alors s'assurer qu'elle
n'est pas disproportionnée ou
incompatible avec les droits de l'homme
le 13 mai 2000 vingt cinq jours avant le
procès la juge vanessa barritt their
décide de reporter une nouvelle fois au
7 septembre la reprise de l'audience
alors que l'épidémie de covile 19 est
très actif dans la prison de belmarsh la
juge refuse à assange la liberté
provisoire même après les demandes de
ses avocats à cause de sa santé déjà
très fragile la mère de ses deux enfants
supplie même la justice britannique pour
qu'il puisse les voir en vain tandis que
le procès de nouveau reporté l'état de
santé du journaliste se dégradent
fortement
il s'agit de sa onzième année de
détention arbitraire dont sept ans à
l'ambassade de l'équateur et maintenant
bientôt deux ans abel marche tout ça
s'accumule psychologiquement il s'agit
d'un lent meurtre les visites sont
désormais de 45 minutes une fois par
mois
il est interdit aux visiteurs ou à ses
enfants de le toucher
sa santé est désastreuse il devrait être
hospitalisé après des années de torture
psychologique et du handicap physique
qui en résulte les associations montent
au créneau en septembre 2020 amnesty
international parle d'un simulacre de
justice et reporters sans frontières
seules ong présentes lors des audiences
de septembre à octobre
lance un cri d'alerté nous avons aussi
de sérieuses inquiétudes d'ordre
humanitaire son extradition pouvant être
pour lui un enjeu de vie ou de mort
enfin les différents obstacles et
dysfonctionnements qui ont rendu notre
rôle d'observateur quasi impossible à
tenir sont inquiétants pour l'ensemble
de ces raisons nous réitérons notre
appel à l'abandon des charges qui pèsent
sur julian assange et à sa libération
immédiate
c'est une évidence ne doit en aucun cas
être extradé aux états unis
plus récemment courant décembre dernier
c'est au tour de nils melzer le
rapporteur spécial des nations unies sur
la torture de se prononcer sur les
conditions de détention totalement
disproportionnée du journaliste les
droits de julian assange ont été
gravement violé pendant plus d'une
décennie
il doit maintenant être autorisés à
vivre une vie familiale sociale et
professionnelle normale a recouvré la
santé et à préparer sa défense de
manière adéquate contre la demande
d'extradition américaine en cours contre
lui
quelle que soit la décision du 4 janvier
la sphère ne s'arrêtera sûrement pas là
chacune des deux parties fera presque
certainement appel selon jennifer
robinson une des avocates de julian
assange
l' affaire ira probablement jusqu'à la
cour suprême britannique ou la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme